welcome everyone to the road to 2000s my
name is Caleb Denby and I will be your
driver on this journey that we take
together so this is the first time this
class is appearing on YouTube I think
I've been doing it at the club for a
while but what I wanted to talk about is
basically the introduction to the class
what we're basically going to be doing
here is I'm gonna be looking at the
different various levels on the way to
2,000 and talking about what I think
could help the most what people need to
work on at each level in order to
improve to that next step to break that
next barrier so since this is the first
class I wanted to start off a little bit
more basic
so what many people have probably heard
if you're around the thousand level or
maybe below is you ask some stronger
player what do I need to do to get
better and more often than not they just
say tactics and then that's the end of
the conversation they give you one word
and they say go do tactics and then get
better I wanted to talk about kind of
what they mean when they say that and
why it helps you improve here so one of
the basic tactics this happens in so
many beginner games it's it's hard to
count you get some position like this
out of an e4 e5 opening and white plays
d4 black moves the bishop and then white
plays d5 so I mean everybody knows in
this room I think what this is called
right it's just a fork right it's a fork
of the bishop and the knight and black
will lose one of the pieces and now so
the fork is the first tactical motif
that many people learn but since most
people know things like the fork and
probably the pin may be things like
discovered attacks I wanted to go over
slightly more advanced technical motifs
just so that you can be introduced to
them because the way I've best heard
tactical motifs introduced is they're
kind of like tools in your toolkit so
once you've learned the fork once you've
learned you know a pawn fork like this
you can use it in any game right you you
can notice these things a lot faster if
you've been introduced to the idea so
that's one tool in your tool kit and
maybe a pin is another tool in your tool
click okay so I want to broaden your set
of tools and see if I can help you
become you know a stronger tactical
player today so another easy one that
you're probably familiar with is the
idea of a trapped piece so what a
trapped piece means is that you know the
piece has no squares to go to and it's
attacked and it really can't be defended
right so let's see here this is maybe a
position that you could get out of the
caro-kann it's a very common one and
let's say black plays something like 97
what would white do here yes so this is
a very common idea it's the reason why
blacks most popular movies h-6 to give
us Bishop this square it's because after
97 white has this H 5 move now this
Bishop is attacked the knight controls
the square when I controls this square
and there's nowhere for the Bishop to go
so on the next turn black is simply
going to lose his bishop and there's
nothing you can do about it another easy
and common tactical motif is still the
trapped piece but this time in a
different manner so Bishop seemed pretty
easy to trap you know it got caught in
front of its own pawns but here what
happens if Queen takes b2 this is
another super common idea so the Queen
has made it to be too it's taken upon
but black is neglected to develop as
other pieces so yeah Knight a 4 is the
very common idea if you don't understand
the Queen is attacking the c3 Knight
it's threatening to escape and it's not
attacked currently so in order to trap
the Queen we need to do we need to stop
all three of these threats with this
move Knight to a4 so if you didn't
understand those they're not too hard so
this isn't really like any fancy kind of
tactics yet this is just simply you're
attacking a piece and the piece has no
escape so this is kind of the basis the
basics of tactics here is it simple it's
direct and you know there's there's not
really any tricks to it the next one is
kind of the first tool that I think
people should learn after
learn about pins and forks and things
such as those so this tactic is called
removing the defender so it's exactly
what it sounds like so let's say in this
game maybe black plays c5 attacking d4
and white plays d5 and so you might
think okay white only has two defenders
and black has three attackers so if
black takes however what can white
achieve here yes so you insert this move
Bishop takes f6 and after Queen takes
orgy tix
now there's simply not enough pieces
left to defend this bishop
why wouldn't Knight takes here work
what's wrong with Knight takes d5 the
other order yeah so the Queen takes on
d5 and then if you take f6 yeah so Queen
takes d1 is a nice in-between move or an
intermezzo so that's actually another
tactic a tactical motif I mean but yet
it's simply Bishop takes f6 removing the
defender of the bishop and then
capturing the bishop so these are kind
of the tactics in their basic form and
so I just wanted to introduce some of
those and then we'll get into more
complicated kind of puzzles with them so
next up is called a deflection or a
distraction depending on who you ask
so does anyone know what a deflection or
a distraction is before we jump into
this intro puzzle here do you know what
that kind of means that tactical oh yeah
you make it move so this happens when a
piece is playing an important role in a
position right so if a piece is playing
an important role and it's forced to
move off of the square that that
performs that role then it's been
deflected or distracted from what of
what its task was so this looks like a
fairly normal position matey
and so what if black threatens to
checkmate us on g2 what can what can
white try here
yeah so why can we fork them yes so it's
uh what pieces being deflected then so
yeah the rook is being deflected so this
is kind of the most common form of
deflection I think this is the one I see
most and my games and in other games is
a player has a weak back rank and it's
got a rook defending this weak back rank
and something happens to make that rook
move so in this case it's gonna be this
knight East seven check move so it looks
like this Knight is hanging but it's
also forking the king and the Queen
which is one of those basic tactical
motifs that I think everybody knows so
after this check we see rook takes and
then we actually have Queen c8 takes
takes and the king is check mated on the
back rank so you can kind of see how
these slightly more complicated tactical
motifs kind of rely on the simpler ones
right so we've used this fork and this
fork forced this rook to be deflected
and then that allowed us to back rank
made him so we've used the fork in the
back rank mate all in order to achieve a
deflection so these things kind of
compound on each other and as you build
to more complicated puzzles and more
complicated tactics you can kind of see
that all these things work together all
these things are important and you know
kind of the more tactical motifs
involved sometimes the more complicated
but once you've got a good handle on
them they become a lot more simple all
right up next we have a mating net so
white would like to checkmate blacks
King right
but I've highlighted here there's an
escape route right the black king can
try to escape through g6 unless white
stops them so do you know what the idea
of a mating net is before we look at
this specifically what does a mating net
mean
yeah basically you want to kind of it
sound it's exactly like it sounds you
want to net the king so you kind of
tighten the net once once you get it
around him so white already has a pretty
tight mating net these 3 squares are all
you know impassable by the black king
and he just has to find a way to get rid
of the last one before delivering the
mate
it looks like the natural move might be
something like g4 but then like I said
there's g6 square and the King can run
away so we need something better than g4
yes so f5 is the natural move you start
with that v the King can't move and it's
actually just checkmate in one there's
no legal move black can play to get out
of this 196 and of course the follow up
now g4 only after we've taken away the
square all right and so I wanted to do a
second mating net puzzle here so and
it's also kind of ignoring a weaker
threat so this is another tactical motif
that I'm introducing so a lot of times
in beginner games or games around V a
thousand level one point it makes the
threat the other person responds the
person makes another threat the person
responds and defense the threat and you
kind of go back and forth like this and
nothing really gets done you kind of
chase each other and the board but here
we see white makes a threat white plays
rook d8 threatening the Queen and here
black is gonna want to ignore this
threat so what can black do to try to
you know counter-attack yes so this h4
move becomes really strong you might be
tempted to play rook h1 check when after
King g3 though there's actually nothing
left for black to do here you can throw
away more pawns but it won't help your
situation white will simply queen and
checkmate you so we need to do something
again to cast a mating net we need to
cut off his escape here and the way to
do that is actually to play h4 so
obviously what happens if white takes
the Queen
yeah Ricca h1 is made but White has a
stronger defense
what else can white try to avoid
checkmate yeah g4 or g3 I think is
better because it blocks the diagonal so
do you see them mate after g3 rook b2
rook d2 and maybe white spawn will be
strong enough to win
yes so we're saying white plays this
move g3 to try to give us King to g2
square yeah so Rakesh won and again the
king is the g2 Square and yet that's
that's the killer blow so we've cast
this mating net and we want to make it
tighter so you plays here to try to you
know give himself some more room try to
escape but luckily we have rook h1 king
g2 and now this Queen move cutting off
again his his escape route and then the
rooks well we'll finish the job after
something like Queen f3 and what's he
probably just rook b2 king h1 Quincy
Queen f3 and me so once again it's this
idea of not playing the natural check
which a lot of people are inclined to do
just right off the bat and first you
know kind of casting this mating net to
keep the king locked in okay let's see
an x-ray attack now does anybody know
what an x-ray tech kind of is yeah it's
like you you're eyeing a piece through
through another enemy piece it's kind of
a weird one but it's actually pretty
intuitive once once you see it on the
board so this one is not so hard it's C
takes d5 what black plays Queen takes d5
and now what can white do here
yeah rook takes p7 and you can kind of
see now this this x-ray idea this rook
is defended through another piece even
though the pieces in the way so when we
tell beginners you know how to count
attackers and defenders we usually just
say okay that'd be one attacker one
defender you know it's just an even
trade
but this Queen is actually a second
attacker through the Queen in this case
all right this is now a clearance
sacrifice so it's exactly like it sounds
but does anybody know oh yeah you want
to clear the way so what that means is a
young piece in your own way basically
your own piece is blocking your other
pieces so you want to do something to
get it out of the way so let's say in
this position black plays rook to d3 yes
so what pieces in the way at first say
this rook is in the way we'd like to
play Queen g7 right but we can't right
now
and so the way to get it out of the way
is you attack with tempo rook h7 either
Knight or King age 7 and then Queen g7
mate and it's just checkmate - up next
we have an interference tactic so again
exactly like it sounds they've named
these quite accurately so here a very
tempting move for white might be to hop
into the seventh rank right we're told
you know rooks on the seventh are always
very strong so we see this move rook to
d7 and unfortunately this is actually a
blunder for white what can black do in
response now
yes so you might think you know maybe I
can attack this Rick somehow maybe Rick
to d8 but these moves actually don't do
anything the best move is actually to
place your knight on the square where
it's hanging with Knight to d4 and this
is actually a super common tactic I see
a lot in games is you know the rooks are
connected on a file like this and you
know somebody thinks okay I can just go
straight down the file no because I've
got got the support but these these
tricky Knight d4 tactics can can crop up
and a lot of games so it's called an
interference because this piece is being
interfered with basically it's it's got
something blocking it now it's it's been
interfered and so white would recapture
and black can win the exchange and maybe
white gets a pawn for it but you know
the exchanges is enough here alright
moving on the desperado so has anyone
heard of the desperado before absolutely
yeah
so again what it basically means is you
know it's I I'm not sure what the actual
translation is from Spanish but you
would think it means desperate but it's
something something to that effect I'm
sure but what this means is you have a
piece that can be captured and your
opponent also has a piece that can be
captured so one way that could resolve
is you capture your opponent's piece and
he captures your piece and then you're
done that wouldn't be a desperado what a
desperado is is when both of these
pieces are intake but then they keep
taking other pieces and rather than
recapture your opponent uses his piece
to take another piece and you kind of
get these these mash trades which
sometimes result and one player winning
more material than the other so let's
see it here so white plays d4 a very
sensible move you know trying to break
down the center but black has something
strong in response
well yeah let's calculate all the way
through so what does whitefly after 94
you can't just give the first move yes
so that works and then exactly so the
placement of the pieces kind of work out
for black in this case so you can take
this if Bishop d8 Knight c3 and then if
white wants to save the bishop he'll
either lose the rook here or maybe even
loser rook here and like we'd win the
exchange again so best for white is
probably to just recapture this Knight
right away and go down the pawn so
that's kind of the desperado you can
kind of see especially in this line you
know so both pieces are being attacked
and so rather than capturing black's
piece white wants to try to you know
take his queen but then both pieces are
attacked rather than recapture the
bishop black would of course want to
retake the queen maybe white wants to
try to win this pawn but then black can
win this rook maybe white traps this
Knight now and the desperado ends and
white will have or black will have the
extra material at the end of the day
just any move and takes and again black
is up the exchange that as well
possibly either F 2 or B - I like F -
yeah
just like that you lose your piece yeah
that's that's the simpler version this
is kind of an extended version but no
it's usually when both sides have a
piece that is attacked and you can kind
of continue down this line like this
where you both capture pieces and
whoever kind of takes the most valuable
pieces along the way ends up being out
on top so this is kind of one of the
more complicated things to actually
calculate all the way through you have
to be sure that okay I'm taking extra
pieces I'm not actually losing but yeah
it's a good one all right here we have
an attraction tactic so it's kind of the
opposite of a deflection tactic and
deflection tactic you kind of force the
piece away from something and an
attraction tactic you try to draw a
piece towards you or towards a specific
square so here black plays rook takes b3
White's now down upon what can white do
to uh Swinson material back yes the
Queen c2 is one option right but this
one it be attractions would be a fork so
the rooks detect the pawns attacks
zurich travels back you and this pawn
back but actually now the material is
just even and maybe this a pawn is going
to be strong in the endgame maybe it'll
be weak but white can do better
Queen a2 doesn't make so much sense this
pawn is simply hanging this Bishop can
come in next well if you take then this
Bishop singing so I was thinking maybe
yet to save this Bishop they should be
for this looks very good for black so
why that move yeah so uh yeah it's all
about move order here so you have to
take on h7 first if King takes h7 the
natural move now you've drawn the king
forward you've attracted the king to
this square and on the square you now
have this fork available so the king
will retreat and the rook is the Rick is
captured this would win the exchange as
well as the pawn back
if he doesn't take the bishop that's the
other problem you have to calculate so
King h8 it's the only other move and now
unfortunately why is Queen h5 a bad move
I'm sorry I was gonna say Queen h5 but
obviously it's this is the wrong choice
yeah simply Knight f6 would be crushing
and this bishop actually does hang this
time so we need to do better after King
h8 we have something better here
where
if you just go back to d3 he'll play
night of 6 and then defend yes so you
have this move Bishop c2 gaining time on
the rook allowing need to do this so
black would be forced to play Knight of
6 and now you actually win a forward
Rock instead of the exchange so black
should take on h7 so again you're
attracting the king to a square it
doesn't want to be on with this move so
Queen c2 so I think you might want to
head over to the tournament pretty soon
alright I think Mike was peeping in the
window trying to look for you good luck
all right moving along this motif is a
little bit different than the others so
most of these motifs rely on threats to
a piece or threats to the King so those
are one types of threat and then they
use those threats in an interesting way
to either like attract so a piece or
deflect a piece in this case this isn't
so much you know using those threats but
it's a different form of a threat so the
form of the threat in this case is the
advanced pawn so the advanced pawn is
kind of threatening to win material in a
totally different way instead of taking
a piece to go up material it's
threatening to promote right but this is
the same kind of threat and it can be
used in the same way with the same kind
of tactics so what do you think white
can do here white has to do something
pretty immediately or else he will end
up losing this endgame in a horrible
fashion yeah so there are a couple
logical options right so Rick c2 is the
first option what are the what's the
other option
really yeah so rook d6 you might be
tempted to first play rook d8 but this
actually doesn't really accomplish
anything black can simply play anything
and you don't really have a threat here
but one of these two moves is correct
one of these is incorrect
I'm interested if you can figure out why
first off let me just show the idea so
the idea is rook c2 if black does
nothing we're gonna take here and now
what kind of tactic is this moves
specifically yes so it's a deflection
using the threat of the advanced pawn
this phone is on an important square so
we deflect it away
and now we can follow through on our
threat to gain material so that's kind
of what I mean when I say the advanced
pawn is you know a different form of a
threat rather than its own tactical
motif so why is rook c2 better than our
d6 yes so the problem with rook d6 is
this 92 move when after Knight d4 we can
no longer deflect the pawn because the
knight can recapture so we simply play
York c2 instead to stop this 92 idea and
next move we're going to take this
bishop or black well have to move away
when we can capture this pawn and easily
promote so that's kind of what I mean
when I say you know it's it's it's own
threat it's not like it's not the same
thing as a deflection or an attraction
or a desperado it's it's a kind of a
threat alright so now I wanted to show
how strong an advanced pawn can be in a
real game so this is a game I had
against a grandmaster very recently and
I had the black pieces sadly you know I
don't know if you could tell but maybe
black is the one defending here and
first let me show you how the how the
game went so I played the move rook to
c2 trying to trade off some pieces
he took her right away I recaptured this
pawn was attacked and white decided hey
there's no rush there's no need for me
to rush to try to promote my pawn right
away my position is superior so he just
plays recce 1 and now I couldn't really
figure out what to do here I simply
played to work back to c5 you play the
Queen to d8 attacking my Bishop ship c6
Queen decease Queen to d6 attacking my
Bishop again so now already they're a
bunch of
acta motifs and involved in this move
first of all this bishop is attacked so
I need to do something with it if I were
to take here now the threat of the
advanced pawn is preventing me from you
know it's preventing me from doing this
because now the pawn would queen or my
queen would be deflected and my rook
would be captured so it's kind of the
idea with this Queen d6 move it uses
these tactical motifs to gain an
advantage so I simply have to move my
Bishop again now he plays rook a1 I play
b4 and now see if you can spot the
tactic here
yeah so you both got at the same time
it's actually gonna be Queen takes c5
again it's the same kind of deflection
tactic this time instead of a pawn we're
deflecting we're deflecting the Queen
and after a seven I resigned so with all
that in mind let's back up to the
original position so knowing that you
know this advanced pawn is such a
massive threat to the position what
might black play here yeah I can flip
the board so what do you think is a
better try for for black than rook c2 is
what I played in the game any other
ideas
everything that the English great
so yeah my original idea in the game was
to actually do nothing for the rest of
the game but I got kind of nervous so I
tried to work see to to see if I could
make something happen but I think that
was wrong
Bishop e8 might be actually just holding
it might be kind of a fortress but again
why it's going to have a very pleasant
game he can just kind of shuffle around
make various threats movie will threaten
to open up the Kings side at some point
and I think maybe you know I would
probably collapse in a real game against
against a GM especially I was in time
pressure as well so what Ryan suggested
is actually probably blacks best option
we take here and white ticks and now we
actually have two options here we can
take White's Queen or White's pawn I
actually I think the better option is to
take the pawn this is a similar position
but White's Queen is just kind of more
active so you would take here so in this
case the threat of the advanced pawn was
actually worth the full Queen and now I
think this position is actually
approximately equal because there's
nothing white can do to break through
well he has to babysit this pawn and
there's no way white can take this pawn
with this bishop on the board but black
is done in exchange so it's not like
he's pressing so this is kind of how
these threats are used in a real game
this is an advanced pawn and because of
the advanced pawn there are so many
tactics so many threats on every move
that my position kind of collapsed next
I want to go over a very common opening
trap and so this has actually happened
over 1,500 times only chess it's an
eighth move game ending in checkmate so
I wanted to go over some of the motifs
that occur directly off of the start of
the game maybe maybe so it starts with
d4 and now black plays the England
actually with E 5 so just sacrificing
this pawn right away it's not very good
for black but it's something that people
play thousands and thousands of time
apparently so white takes the pawn
accepting the gambit the best move
Knight to c6 threatening to regain the
pawn Knight of three defending and now
comes the first kind of you know
unnatural move for black but it's it's
the main line in the opening what do you
think it is any idea so it's kind of the
point of the way of black plays not not
quite not quite we actually want to we
really want to regain this pawn because
giving up your ePHI pawn is is terrible
and even England players realize this so
Queen e7 is the move just attacking here
and you might think well this is no big
deal I can defend the pawn again right
so what's the most natural move yeah
it's simply Bishop f4 and so now now
comes a point of blacks place so here
comes our first tactic so what motif is
this it's a fork right the basic one so
the most natural move again is Bishop to
d2
black takes this pawn and now we see
another motif well the motif is that
this rook is trapped right it's a
trapped piece so white has to do
something to defend it so what move
would you play alright you fallen from
the trap that's very good and now we see
another motif from black what do you
think black plays yeah yet another motif
so this is motif number four already and
where five moves into the game where six
so what do you think white would play
here what's what's the most natural way
to try to keep all your pieces
yes the Queen due to makes the most
sense right kind of unpinning and I
don't know if you want to call unpinning
a motif but in my opinion it kind of is
so we're unpinning we're renewing our
x-ray defense of this rook this Queen is
also a trapped piece now things are
looking kind of dire for for black so
you might think well maybe there's a
desperado here so what can black do to
get a favorable desperado
yeah so let's clean the techs you take a
piece with with your dead pieces already
white recaptures you take care you take
care and you're up in exchange right so
you might think you know that's good
enough black would play that but
fortunately for white black heads better
springs are our last motif into the into
the mix
yeah so Bishop c3 and then Queen c3
defending the rook and then the points
mean c1 mate
the mating net or mate threat whatever
you whatever motif you you want to call
it so this move
this is move eight and this has happened
over 1,500 times only chess so if you've
seen this video don't do that instead
after Queen - B - white can simply play
Knight to c3 and is better in this
position because the screen is out of
play this phone has survived for the
moment and after this move we will
simply have rook to be won and something
like her to be three maybe maybe just
anything else maybe ninety four ninety
five
it all seems fun so yeah don't don't
fall for that but as you can see their
motifs everywhere right that was an
eight move game and there were something
like seven or eight types cool motifs
involved obviously this is more tactical
than the most eight move game
well most games at move eight not Moe
statement games probably but you can see
how these things all kind of work
together and you know you know one motif
is kind of countered by another motif so
there's the defense and the trapped
Queen and then there's the pin on the
bishop to prevent it and then there's
you know the option of the desperado or
this mate threat and you know they all
kind of come together to make a coherent
coherent game in combination I have
another real game example here this game
was played by a friend of mine named Gus
so what happened in this game is pretty
easy
something like Bishop before check King
e6
and now see if you can find the next
move the next move for white there are a
few moves that kind of win or keep the
winning position but one move really
seals the deal
yes so why a king g5 so yeah so what
motif is that say it's creating a mating
net with King to g5 what do you think
black can do in response
rook e8 maybe right so yeah so Rick eh
but then uh how can white breakthrough
yeah simply a six right so we've used a
few motifs here right we've created a
mating net which has forced black to
deflect his Rucka way from the a file
and after a six maybe we see something
like Bishop d3 simply a seven and now we
use the threat of the advanced pawn
I don't know Bishop a six Queen and now
if York takes the work has actually been
deflected back away from the mate threat
and we can deliver the checkmate so this
is how the game might have gone I think
in reality the opponent Gus's opponent
actually just resigned after a six but
you can kind of see it kind of goes back
and forth he's this one threat with the
advanced pawn one throw with the mate
net and it can deflect the rook until uh
blacks pieces simply can't handle it
anymore okay let's look at another
example in a real game this is another
game I had I think at Pan Am's and so we
had played a very long and complicated
game up to this point and now my
opponent unfortunately made this move
which is a blunder so what can white do
here
probably yes so it's it's rook takes
Knight so this is again removing the
defender or capturing the defender and
now you know maybe you could say it's a
desperado if black tried to take this
rook what's the best move for white is
there anything besides taking the Queen
yeah you're all too smart I had to throw
a trick question so yeah it's just Queen
takes Queen pawn takes rook and yeah the
this should this should be game maybe
just d6
that's what I was thinking about for a
second if d6 worked or not so if you
played d6 I guess you're using the
advanced pawn motif
there's the desperado motif there's the
remove the the defender motif again all
these motifs come together and they make
up the ends to an actual game that
actually happened
all right last I have a puzzle for you
to solve this one is parenthesis
difficult as I've written on the screen
so if you can solve this one I think
you're officially a master of most of
these motifs
well mastered enough for the beginner
level so the motifs include attraction
clearance distraction double attack
interference a mating net and a trapped
piece so can all of those seven motifs
be combined into one puzzle here you're
welcome to try to find out I'll give you
some time
9 g5 what's the idea it captures h7 tha
Bishop e6 e7 Jack da Rippa Jake check th
a queen in Chongqing g8 and me so why
does he have to capture it though
very well done out of the way but what
but what if he doesn't what if he
doesn't capture your night
which allows what you're just saying
words I know I know what you saying all
right can't you can't fake your way
through this one
just feels like there's something there
everything we do is away from them it
does feel like there's something there
it's 95 Queen f6 we have 97 you have to
win the game I think what if Queen e7
instead
right because the the rook is trapped so
for the YouTube years you didn't hear
any of that probably what we're talking
about is this line coming up so if you
wanna if you haven't solved it yet
and you want the chance to do it you're
gonna want to pause the video now if you
have solved it you just want to see the
answer it's actually gonna be this move
Knight to g5 so already this move is
kind of a double attack it's threatening
this Queen and it's also threatening
Knight h7 these are the two attacks so
it's not a direct double attack but it
is threatening the Queen and also
another threat so Queen d7 makes the
most sense to me if you're not gonna
take the knight that is and then nine h7
and this work is actually a trapped
piece so we've done a double attack and
we've gone a trapped piece already and
so the main line you might think is is H
takes G so if you've gotten this far and
you haven't quite seen the solution yet
and you want to give it a shot from this
position you're more than welcome but
the main problem is you'd like to play
something like queen h5 or more directly
something like rook h8 Queen h5 and
queen h7 but obviously there's a problem
with this right the problem is whoops
let's see the problem is simply Queen h6
here and then white would be losing and
if you don't sac the rook and play Queen
H by first still Queen h6 is defending
well enough defending well enough so you
have to find some way to keep this this
Queen out of the h6 square so you play
this Bishop h7 check and after King h8
you have Bishop g6
casting and mating net and now of course
this Knight move was also acting as
clearance for this Queen to get in and
lastly I think I've mentioned everything
the worldís pawn was distraction and now
we need the attraction and that comes in
the form of this jerk h8 move forcing
the King onto the H file so we can
move there with check and now after King
g8 the game is over
so if you solve that puzzle quickly
kudos to you because that used well over
five or six you know tactical motifs so
I think you've you've got these down
pretty well any questions about any of
these puzzles I went over today or any
of the motifs in general so still
tactics and pattern recognition is the
main thing but what I was trying to go
over well the question was you know how
do you get better I said most people
just say tactics and so what's my answer
to the question it's still gonna be
these these tactics and just playing war
chests but so what I was trying to go
over is these are the motifs that make
up tactics so this is what you should be
looking for when you're doing tactics
and this is what kind of makes mixed
tactics happen so this is kind of your
starting point to figuring out how
techniques work and how you can find
them in your own games is recognizing
these types of patterns yeah other than
that if you thought some of these are a
little bit too hard there is a cool
feature on Lee chest I wanted to show
you guys which you two are probably well
beyond this but it's actually this
practice feature and so if you want to
learn some more basic tactics like the
ones I didn't cover today you can check
this out they go everything is like the
pin the fork double check in between
moves or resolutions ooks
overloaded pieces skewers and discovered
attacks as well as a few more things so
this is Lee chested org slash practice
other than that if you want to check out
the study I've actually created a
account just for this class so it's
called STL Road - mm and if you want I
think this is going to be linked in the
description maybe of the YouTube video
if you're interested
get out and yet you can flip through
these yourself check it out
ask the computer what it thinks about
these these different puzzles and motifs
and yeah
do whatever you whatever you wish with
them so thank you all for coming out
thank you guys for watching on YouTube
it's it's gonna be back teaching at the
club I'm glad I can teach my own class
my own way thanks very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]